Exploring the unintended consequences of a safety first culture through the lens
of a quarantine was to me a really interesting rumination
because we can be a safety first country, but only for very, very,
very short periods of time.
And then we're reminded that the chief goal of,
of living is not to merely stay alive.
Before we do anything else.
There's a million things that I want to talk to you about,
but we're in this strange COVID time, obviously. Uh,
we're both in California, not in the same town,
but we're both here in California where it does seem like we're going to be one
of the last to open up.
And we've got a lot of kind of big government officials here that seem to be at
least from my position encroaching on our rights at this point. Um, well,
first of all, I guess just, what's your take on the lockdown specifically,
maybe a bit about California since you live here.
And then I want to talk about getting back to work and the importance of working
and things like that.
Sure, sure. I, um,
I've been comparing it to the Kubler-Ross five
stages of grief, right? I mean,
the country's grieving in a sense,
but we're all at different levels and we're all grieving at different
speeds.
And we're trying to process a lot of information
and a lot of data without a ton of context or perspective.
And so what you wind up getting with that in my view anyway,
is the opportunity to look around and go, Oh, look,
he's in denial and he's bargaining and she's
depressed and she's angry and that one's accepted it,
but what have they accepted exactly?
Have they accepted the reality of the virus,
the reality of the lockdown or this weird space that
requires us to somehow navigate both?
And so I early on wrote a piece
called safety third,
which borrowed the title from a special I did for discovery back in 2008,
where I ruminated on the unintended consequences of a culture that truly
elevates safety to an unrealistic place on some hierarchy.
Uh, the safety first culture,
the safety first mentality with regard to vocational work
is, is fascinating because it's rife with unintended consequences. When you,
when you put safety at the top of the thing.
And when you tell your employees or your customers that,
that their safety is your top priority,
you set the table in a very strange way.
And it's a way that oftentimes in my view, anyway, fosters, uh,
complacency among the very customers and employees who should be
really taking a measure of personal responsibility for their own actions.
So exploring the unintended consequences of a safety first culture through the
lens of a quarantine was to me a really interesting
rumination because we can be a safety first country, but only for very,
very, very short periods of time.
And then we're reminded that the chief goal of,
of living is not to merely stay alive, at least not, not for most people.
And then this fascinating conversation starts to unfold.
So that's a long way of saying that for the last 60 days or so.
I've seen a lot,
a lot of conversation right around a couple of topics that I love
specifically, homeostatic risk, compensatory, risk,
risky equilibrium,
and all of the subconscious things we do to maintain our own, uh,
illusory relationship with the illusion of safety.
So let's talk about those types of risk a little bit,
because you've worked with a ton of people who take all sorts of crazy risks in
their day-to-day jobs all the time.
Do you sense that maybe we've hit the limit as we enter sort of
now two months or roughly eight weeks of lockdown that we've sort of hit the
limit where now it's like, okay, we did what we had to do,
but what I'm sensing at least here in LA where, you know, it's pretty lefty.
People are willing to accept, you know, a lot of government,
but now when I'm walking my dog, my, my neighbors, you know,
they're suddenly going, we gotta be outside now. Like it's 85 and sunny,
why am I not at the beach right now that that's something I'm not even talking
about.
The people that have had their lives destroyed and lost jobs and every does,
I'm talking just sort of the regular people who walk around in a sort of days
about what reality is all the time, but even they're starting to tilt now. Um,
are,
are you sort of amazed at the way we don't look at risk normally until suddenly
it smacks us in the face?
Well, yes, because look, we're just not used to it yet.
And part of the reason we're not used to it is because it's just a staggering,
new thing to get your head around.
But it's also hard to get used to a thing when the goalposts are constantly
moved when the data is constantly shifting. And most of all,
when the experts themselves are in violent disagreement,
this is the most disconcerting thing to people. And,
and I'm sure you've spoken about it is one of the,
in that same article that I wrote early on was this idea that, I mean,
here's Neil Ferguson, right? He's very,
very clear in his projections and his modeling and,
and here's John I and ed sat down at Stanford and he's saying, look,
I just don't, um, I'm looking at the same data. I'm not disputing the data,
but I just don't think it's reliable. And these two big brain guys, you know,
one's predicting 80,000 fatalities in this country, others 2.2 million,
somebody is not just wrong. Somebody is very, very, very, very wrong.
And so, you know, when,
when you look at that through the lens of a fake
news culture where the sources are inherently
unreliable and where everything is politicized, you know,
it's not unreasonable for the average American to look around
and be skeptical, you know, and it's,
and it's not unpatriotic to want to look at this thing from all sides and kick
the tires and to your question, we're creatures of, uh,
visual stimulation. You know,
we take our cues from a thousand different things that happen around us all of
the time. And you're right when the sun goes out and the breeze is warm and,
and it's like, this is when we're supposed to be doing X, Y, and Z,
but we can't. And we don't because time is somehow bent.
And I don't know, but I mean, it's, it's, it's been hard for me personally,
to concentrate. I thought when this happened,
I was going to sit down and take a few months and write, I love to write,
I write mostly on planes. Now, finally, I have a chance to do this.
I can't, it's all I can do to get my podcast up once a week now.
And, um,
and part of the reason is because I'm genuinely curious to
stay informed or at least try to make sense of the next
deal. It's like somebody dealing the cards, Dave, and they just don't stop.
They just keep coming and you think you're playing one game and now you're in a
completely different game. It's back to the stages of grief.
Everybody is always starting over and trying to figure out where they are and,
uh, what 330 million people are doing that contemporaneously.
It's a hell of a thing.
Yeah.
I love that analogy because it's not only as if they're playing with unlimited
cards,
but it's also that you don't know whether you're playing poker or some other
game, or they're going to flip it in the middle or something else.
Like we're just sort of stuck in this endless thing.
So then how does a guy like you, who has a pre ice,
I assume you consider yourself someone with a pretty high risk threshold.
I mean,
how do you decide when you have to now start taking risks and going out either
with, or without a mask, or just,
just not listening to whatever that as you described,
we have this fake news thing out there when,
when you're not going to listen to the narrative anymore.
Well, this is the it's, it's, it's the eternal paradox,
because the honest answer in normal times to your question is,
is deeply personal risk is personal, right?
This is why risk compensation, uh, is so interesting.
You have a hundred people in a room.
Everybody has a slightly different tolerance for risk. And when you enter the,
when you introduce protocols, safety features, for instance, um,
the theory that your behavior will change to suit
the measures you take. For instance,
if you wear a seatbelt studies show, you drive faster.
If you wear a helmet on your motorcycle studies show you corner faster,
the more safety features you put on a machine,
the more likely the operator is to assume a level of risk
that is slightly heightened. Why? Because there's a,
there's a thing in our brain that wants to keep the risk homeo
in a, in a, in a homeostatic state, right?
So Reese risk equilibrium is the thing that says you subconsciously
adjust your behavior to adapt to your circumstances was perfectly rational.
But as you start to introduce new safety protocols,
subconscious things start to happen.
Why for instance are the most dangerous intersections in the world.
The ones that have the crosswalks and the little guy telling you when the walk
in part it's, because it trains us to look at the little guy walking.
And when we see him walking,
we step off the curb and then the big blue bus takes us out, right?
Because we've been trained not to look. So
something is happening right now with regard to public safety
and individual responsibility. It's a collision.
For more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles instead of nonstop
yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.